al menos 28 personas sufrieron
agresiones sexuales a manos de policías
durante el paro nacional de 2021 en
Colombia según el informe de amnistía
internacional se trató de un patrón
generalizado de violencia Estatal las
violaciones de Derechos Humanos tuvieron
lugar principalmente en dos situaciones
durante la actuación de la Policía
Nacional para dispersar las protestas y
durante las detenciones que siguieron a
la intervención inicial en ambas
situaciones actuando a título oficial
hubo agentes de la Policía Nacional que
cometieron actos que iban desde los
insultos sexistas y las amenazas hasta
la violencia sexual la organización
describió específicamente los 28 casos
de las cientos de denuncias recibidas el
informe de 68 páginas presenta el
contexto de violencia previo a las
protestas que vivía el país así como los
casos de impunidad y las limitaciones
para la atención y garantía de acceso a
la justicia
in relation no ha habido ni una sola
condena en relación con las múltiples
violaciones de Derechos Humanos
cometidos durante estas protestas y ni
una sola condena penal en relación con
la violencia sexual el gobierno debe
reconocer lo que sucedió públicamente
con firmeza debe disculparse por lo que
se hizo con los cuerpos de jóvenes con
la mujer y la juventud y con los
afrocolombianos
según amnistía internacional los abusos
de índole sexual tuvieron lugar entre el
28 de abril y el 30 de junio de 2021
cuando miles de colombianos salieron a
las calles para rechazar la gestión del
gobierno del entonces presidente Iván
Duque